hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
from Wine Library TV with a hundred and
twenty seconds about something besides
wine topic number one Radiohead is
making a lot of noise for giving out
this you know new CD and you can pay
whatever you want is it me or if a lot
of talented wonderful amazing people
been giving away free content for a
little while now I don't know what the
big deal is just cuz they sing it it
shouldn't be such a big news making
event I know it's changing the industry
but the world's been changed for a while
people open up the eyes speaking of eyes
I've got my eyes on you Derek Jeter it's
time to call you out you choked hard in
the fifth inning the other day ending
the Yankees momentum in that game and
ending their season now if that was a
rod the whole city would be talking
about it
ESPN everybody but because it's Jeter no
one's talking about now here's the
question why is that I'm gonna tell you
why it is the big topic for me today
it's branding once you establish
yourself as a brand it's very hard to
break one nor change Jeter established
as a brand that's in the clutch a rod
established as a brand that chokes the
funny thing is it takes a long time to
break that a rod hit a homer nobody's
talking about it she drew up the game
away nobody's talking about it
let me talk to you about another thing
Walmart has more square footage and its
retail stores than the entire square
footage of Manhattan can you believe
that that is shocking and made me think
mine library has a heck of a lot more
square footage than the park across the
street maybe I can get a little bit of
news for that finally Keifer Sutherlands
going to jail jack bauer going to jail
how is he gonna get out that's gonna be
a big drama I know he's got some great
MacGyver type moves I doubt it he's
gonna show him this his Hollywood card
and I predict instead of 48 days we're
looking at 4.8 minutes and finally
must-see TV tonight on revision3 Martin
Sargeant's web drifter show that's
must-see TV in 2007